en busca de una segunda selecciones en
Grecia Y es que el Primer Ministro
conservador curiacos mitsutakis arrasó
en los comicios de este domingo pero sin
lograr los escaños suficientes en el
parlamento parece que mitsutakis no
quiere buscar una coalición sino que
busca gobernar en solitario Durante los
próximos cuatro años y atribuyó su
Victoria a la recuperación económica del
país
[Música]
juntos daremos la próxima batalla
empieza mañana para que en las próximas
elecciones lo que el pueblo ya decidió
una nueva democracia con mayoría
absoluta se confirme también
matemáticamente en las urnas
el líder del partido Nueva democracia en
el poder desde 2019 aventajó con más de
20 puntos porcentuales al Principal
opositor el partido izquierdista siritza
encabezado por el ex Primer Ministro
Alexis quien pese al batacazo electoral
su formación perdió más de 10 puntos
felicitó a su rival
costoso el ciclo electoral sin embargo
aún no ha terminado dado que
probablemente habrá una segunda
selecciones por lo tanto no podemos
permitirnos el lujo del tiempo debemos
llevar a cabo inmediatamente todos los
cambios necesarios para poder librar la
próxima batalla electoral
no logra formar gobierno en un plazo de
72 horas a partir del lunes la
responsabilidad pasa al segundo partido
más votado si fracasa al tercero de no
conseguirlo la Constitución griega
Establece que se deben convocar nuevas
elecciones en menos de 40 días